hi and welcome to this fourth and final
week of this course on konglish the
neural networks by now you've learned a
lot about confidence what I want to do
this week is show you a couple important
special applications of confidence
we'll start to face recognition and then
go on later this week to neuro style
transfer which you get to implement in
the probing exercise as well to create
your own art world but first let's start
of face recognition and just a fun I
want to show you a demo when I was
leaving by this AI Group one of the
team's I worked with led by yen Ching
Lin had built a face recognition system
that the thoughts is really cool let's
take a look so I'm going to play this
video here but I can also get the
whoever's editing this the wrong video
can figure out it is better to splice in
the raw video or take the one out
playing here though there should be a
face recognition demo other I do
stakeholders in China most company is
required to get inside you swipe in our
mind and call like this one but here we
don't think that using face recognition
check out what I could do with a walk
out my face it says welcome just walk
right through let me show you something
else I wish you here would leave your
teeth the director
but I can buy RFID heart which has my
face printed on it and it's gonna do
sent each other sleek new using my
picture instead of a live human ok I'm
not using Andrews card and I try to
sneak in and see what happens so the
season is not organizing so he said you
cannot refuse to log a nice yeah okay
now going to use my own face
let me go home so face recognition
technology like this is taking on every
rap in China and I hope that December 10
oh yes it makes its way to so pretty
cool right the video you just saw demos
both face recognition as well as
liveness detection the latter meaning
making sure that you are a live human it
turns out life detection can be
implemented using supervised learning as
well to predict live human versus not
live human but I want to spend less time
on that instead I want to focus our time
on talking about how to build the face
recognition portion of the system first
let's start by going over some of the
terminology used in face recognition in
the face recognition literature people
often talk about face verification and
face recognition this is the face
verification problem which is if you're
given an input image as well as a name
or an ID of a person and the job of the
system is to verify whether or not the
input image is data to clean person so
sometimes this is also called a
one-to-one problem where you just want
to know if the person is the person they
claim to be so the recognition problem
is much harder than the verification
problem to see why let's say you have a
verification system that's 99% accurate
so 99% might not be too bad but now
suppose that K is equal to 100 in a
recognition system if you apply this
system to a recognition task with a
hundred people in your database you now
have a hundred times of chance of making
a mistake and if the chance of making a
mistake on each person is just 1% so if
you have a database of a hundred persons
and if you want an acceptable
recognition error you might actually
need a verification system with maybe
99.9 or even higher accuracy before you
can run it on a database of a hundred
persons and have a high chance and still
have a high chance of getting incorrect
in fact if you have a database of
hundred persons you probably need this
to be even quite a bit higher than 99%
for that to work well but what we'll do
in the next few videos is focus on
building a face verification system as a
building block and then if the accuracy
is high enough then you'll be able to
use that in a recognition system as well
so in the next video we'll start
describing how you can build a face
verification system it turns out one of
the reasons that is a difficult problem
is you need to solve a one-shot learning
problem let's see in the next video what
that means